Buonasera Allora io mi chiamo Gianfranco
Bacchi come è già stato detto e per la
maggior parte di voi risulterà uno
sconosciuto e la maggior parte di voi si
chiederà Per quale motivo mi trovo su
questo palco Ecco devo dire che è una
domanda che mi sono fatto anch'io e mi
sono chiesto perché mi trovo su questo
palco Probabilmente se l'ai chiesto
anche Andrea Pauli quando mi ha invitato
a scrivere un pezzo sul tema del del
miracolo e io ho risposto che mi sarei
preso 30 minuti perché questa è la mia
massima capacità di concentrazione e per
potere scrivere questo pezzo dopo 29
minuti ve lo giuro ho chiuso il file e
l'ho mandato ed eccomi qua a presentarvi
un un percorso sul tema del Miracolo
secondo la prospettiva di un marinaio Io
ho vissuto tutta la
vita in piccole medie e grandi
comunità abitate da da individui che
avevano la stessa la stessa lingua ma Un
differente linguaggio linguaggio e
lingua Sono due cose completamente
diverse il linguaggio ha a che fare con
le abitudini con con la storia la
cultura che ognuno di noi porta con sé
bagaglio di esperienze e queste comunità
avevano la caratteristica di di avere
delle interazioni in un ambiente
estremamente inst e fortemente
perturbato che si chiama
mare ora per me è sempre stato
estremamente affascinante capire come
all'interno di queste di queste navi di
queste comunità piccole medie o grandi
si riuscissero a instaurare dei rapporti
interpersonali straordinari nonostante
le differenze di linguaggio è sempre
stato un qualcosa che per me ha avuto
una luce di miracolo sopra
e E tutto questo avveniva con una certa
semplicità
incredibilmente
semplice creare questo questo gruppo
questa famiglia in spazi estremamente
ridotti tutto questo funzionava perché
c'era un obiettivo comune io me lo sono
chiesto e mi sono dato una risposta
l'obiettivo comune eraa era la missione
era lo scopo Lo scopo del viaggio per
cui sotto Questo obiettivo la comunità
viveva in un clima familiare poi
capitava una una perturbazione una
burrasca una forte burrasca e
l'obiettivo comune veniva sostituito
dall'obiettivo individuale cioè ognuno
dei marinai pensava alla sua
sopravvivenza scattava lo spirito
autoconservazione diverso in maniera
miracolosa Fra l'altro con con delle
storie che solo i marinai riescono a
raccontarsi in maniera
Così così eclatante raddoppiando
chiaramente l'altezza delle onde e
triplicando la forza del
vento Questa era era la comunità di
marinai in cui ho vissuto per per 35
anni della mia
vita maggio 2023 maggio 2023 ehm
alluvione in Emilia Romagna la mia
Emilia Romagna Io sono Romagnolo per cui
sono un alluvionato non un alluvionato
fisico ma un alluvionato geografico Nel
senso che non sono stato colpito
fisicamente nella persona e nei miei
effetti l'Emilia Romagna è una regione
che
è estremamente complessa con grandi
divisioni è divisa anche nel nome Emilia
e Romagna ha delle divisioni storiche
delle divisioni culturali religiose
ha delle divisioni politiche e poi delle
divisioni sportive incredibili che un
panismo sportivo che forse ha pochi
paragoni cò nonostante il popolo
dell'Emilia Romagna è un popolo
estremamente unito estremamente coeso è
riconosciuto come tale perché ha dei
valori comuni ha degli obiettivi comuni
Quindi l'obiettivo delle comunità di
mare Io l'ho visto anche nel nella
comunità del della mia ziona dell'Emilia
Romagna obiettivi comuni valori come
l'accoglienza come la la volontà di di
di aggregazione Ehm come anche la
generosità E l'operosità in Emilia
Romagna si dice che si mette poca acqua
nel
vino Ecco questa questa
comunità di gente quindi alla fine molto
unita viene viene
perturbata da questo da questo evento
dall'alluvione
l'alluvione l'alluvione scalza
l'obiettivo comune e fa scattare gli
obiettivi individuali quindi la
sopravvivenza ognuno di noi si è
impegnato per sopravvivere per salvare
la sua casa per salvare la famiglia per
salvare i beni e i
cari Tutto questo per la durata delle
dell'evento meteorologico catastrofico
Dopodiché è scattata la solidarietà la
comunità si è riunita si è
rinsaldata nonostante i linguaggi
diversi le divisioni e è diventata una
comunità più forte di prima e io da che
cosa Me ne sono accorto me ne sono
accorto perché io ho visto tutto da
fuori Io non ci sono mai a casa nel nel
bene e nel male per cui in questo caso
nel male ero lontano da casa ho chiamato
Mi sono assicurato che che a casa mia i
miei familiari stessero bene che la mia
casa fosse fosse salva poi con calma
sono
tornato Sono tornato e quando sono
entrato for lì ho visto un un paesaggio
di devastazione
ehm un paesaggio un ambiente surreale
per cui mi sono diretto a casa Ho preso
una pala e poi sono scappato in un
centro commerciale per per acquistare un
paio di stivali di gomma e quando sono
entrato in questo centro commerciale mi
sono accorto che C'erano centinaia di
persone che volevano acquistare stivali
di gomma Quindi da lì sei uscito dopo
qualche ora forse la cosa più
incredibile è che queste persone che
acquistavano stivali di gomma La maggior
parte di di loro non era stata colpita
fisicamente dall'alluvione ma era lì per
acquistare stivali per andare ad aiutare
gli altri
per cui siamo usciti io mi sono diretto
ne uno dei punti più colpiti sono
entrati in un cortile e ho iniziato a
scavare ho iniziato a spalare fango
difan Anche a me è arrivato un ragazzo
con una cariola senza dire una parola io
riempivo la cariola e lui portava via la
cariola L'ho fatto per decine di volte
Forse centinaia fino a quando ho
iniziato a sentire un forte dolore al
collo per cui mi sono accorto che forse
avevo riempito un po' troppe cariole
quindi nel silenzio con cui ero arrivato
me ne sono andato e nel trag ito da da
quel cortile alla macchina ho osservato
e ho osservato uno spettacolo
meraviglioso nella devastazione sono
spettacolo umano di reazioni umane erano
tutti con una pala e con degli stivali
di gomma tutti sporchi di fango tutti
sorridenti sorrideva chi dava una mano e
sorrideva chi
riceveva per cui devo dire che è stato
veramente un effetto che ha avuto del
Miracolo ai miei occhi Io mi sono
commosso e porterò sempre con me questa
immagine
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora faccio un passo indietro ottobre
2019 ottobre 2019 Io ricevo un in
consegna una comunità una comunità di
circa 400 persone con un obiettivo ben
chiaro uno scopo del viaggio ben chiaro
io avrei dovuto fare un giro del mondo
Quindi avrei dovuto portare questa
comunità in giro per il mondo e prima in
Giappone poi attraversare il Pacifico
scendere doppiare capor E poi rientrare
un viaggio di 18 mesi 33 porti Quindi
avrei attraversato tutti gli oceani
quindi con questo obiettivo con questo
scopo Ancora una volta ho creato una
comunità l'ho creata perché perché la
comunità che ho avuto in consegna in
realtà non era pronta per un viaggio del
genere quindi ho dovuto fare degli
avvicendamenti Ho creato una comunità
che si è unita sotto Questo obiettivo
quindi Eravamo una famiglia Noi ci siamo
trovati a marzo 2020 pronti a partire
veramente in famiglia una nave carica di
materiale
materiale che avrebbe dovuto costituire
Il nostro materiale da portare in giro
per il mondo e materiale umano cioè
eravamo noi pronti a partire avete
capito bene marzo 2020 non siamo mai
partiti Ricevo una telefonata che mi
annuncia la cancellazione di questo di
questo viaggio che non era solo un
viaggio era un sogno per molti di noi
molti di noi che avrebbero fatto
l'ultima navigazione compreso
sottoscritto per cui che cosa succede
succede che da una comunità di 400
persone la perturbazione in questo caso
la pandemia disgrega la comunità io devo
mandare via tutti rimaniamo in 30 a
bordo per garantire la sopravvivenza
della nave tutti gli altri se ne vanno e
ognuno pensa alla sua sopravvivenza alla
sopravvivenza personale e della sua
famiglia Il sogno era era
cancellato per cui e come una molecola
che aveva perso i suoi atomi Questa nave
aveva perso il suo carico
umano sono stati mesi molto duri quelli
dal marzo fino a giugno i mesi che tutti
quanti di noi Noi ricordiamo come i mesi
di lockdown comunque della della fase
acuta della pandemia per noi sono stati
duri per questo e anche perché si è
infranto veramente un sogno importante
fino a quando non ho ricevuto un'altra
telefonata una chiamata che mi dice
Prendi l' trave e parti non farei il
giro del mondo ma farei comunque una
lunga
navigazione con il tuo gruppo con il tuo
equipaggio l'obiettivo è quello di
addestrare il carico di allievi che hai
Io avevo 150 allievi a bordo e di
portare un messaggio per il mare un
messaggio di solidarietà
per cui noi sotto questo nuovo obiettivo
ci ricostituiti n mio equipaggio a bordo
e partiamo Quindi l'obiettivo era chiaro
dovevamo portare un messaggio in giro
per il mare e noi portiamo questo
messaggio iniziamo a filmar mentre
lavoriamo ma anche mentre Mentre
giochiamo Mentre Mentre viviamo a bordo
mentre suoniamo mentre dipingiamo
vogliamo far vedere a casa quello che
capita dentro la nave perché perché la
gente non poteva venire a bordo noi che
eravamo abituati a
ricevere 10.000 15.000 visitatori al
giorno non potevamo essere visitati da
nessuno e non potevamo neanche andare in
porto la navigazione era senza una sosta
era una navigazione che veniva
interrotta solamente saltuariamente da
dei da delle ore trascorse all'Ancora in
qualche Rada per cui noi iniziamo a fare
questi video e a mandarli in giro quindi
è una comunità
che si contrae si chiude in spazi minimi
pensate una nave di di 100 m ma in
realtà vivibili ne ha quasi 80 neanche
80 quasi 80 e che ha a bordo 400 persone
è un miracolo di relazioni umane un
miracolo assoluto perché 400 persone
diverse con linguaggi diversi riescono a
vivere all'interno di un guscio per 2
mesi e mezzo bene in una sorta di sogno
per cui Noi andiamo avanti con questo
sogno fino a quando il sogno non deve
per forza arrivare al termine il termine
è questo Cioè ci viene chiesto di
entrare dentro una città
e quasi come chiudere questo Questo
format questo cerchio cioè noi siamo
entrati nelle case dei nostri
connazionali con i nostri video facendo
vedere qual era la vita di bordo e ora
dobbiamo entrare dentro al cuore di una
città attraversando uno stretto
canale questo è stato un momento
meraviglioso sia dal punto di vista
marinaresco soprattutto dal punto di
vista umano perché noi siamo entrati ci
siamo girati poi siamo riusciti siamo
ormeggiati nella sponda che ora vedete a
destra dello schermo e poi abbiamo
deciso
di riunirci in un'assemblea che è durata
pochi minuti un'assemblea che è stata la
giusta conclusione di questo miracolo di
relazioni umane in questa assemblea non
abbiamo detto nulla
ora qui c'è un video di pochi secondi
che riassumono questo momento che non
non serve che io
commenti si va a prendere 5
minuti
pure
[Musica]
[Applauso]
al
contrario non ho nient'altro da dire
Grazie di
nuovo
Questo è il miracolo delle delle
relazioni umane dal punto di vista di un
di un marinaio Io mi chiamo Gianfranco
Bacchi Sono figlio di un camionista di
una camiciaia vengo da Forlì quindi una
città della Pioner Padana e sono il 122
comandante della Merigo Vespucci Se
volete anche questo è un piccolo
miracolo
[Musica]
Grazie
R